if you run for president what kind of
ideas would you represent
that we're beings with engineering
opportunities
I would represent
just as you served a platform here
there's something that happened on my
last run that
I thought I feel I know was brilliant it
was noisy but it was brilliant
I had one rally
and in the rally I just let people come
up and I gave them a platform
it's our responsibility to listen to the
pain and hear the pain and understand
even when
we're the ones that cause the pain like
with my tweet it's my responsibility to
hear you and understand why you feel
like that but it's our responsibility as
the people to understand each other
to give people a voice
people need the voice and even right now
what I'm doing or how God is using me
I'm showing where our voices are being
muted there's
professors that are actually intelligent
actually have multiple degrees that have
been canceled
from their schools
and they don't have a music industry or
a fan base or shoe design or a smoking
hot ex-wife to complain about they've
just got the truth of what they saw and
what they dedicated to this country and
to education that has been muted by
schools that have been taken over with
an agenda and so you're you want the
brightest Minds to be these professors
and then you mute them and they have
nowhere to go and you might get a guy
now that went from being someone's
favorite Professor to he's working at
Starbucks like like he was back at
school or like he was back in high
school
so even if that voice is about anger and
Hate
it still deserves to be heard
yeah it deserves to be heard and we
deserve to ask why you know like you
have to ask why I just feel like that's
what's I feel like that is sympathizing
Mr huge [ __ ] I'm just saying that
it just needs to be
I should change that to your name on
Twitter
while you're still allowed on there yeah
do you think that that would get
censored I feel like they you know they
definitely cut it down some inches uh
the
I'm I'm pointing out this
I'm pointing out this truth no I'm sorry
this is not a Christian thing right uh
and
you know I wonder right there when I say
these jokes
is it something that I because I do feel
like laughter is the key engineering and
laughter right is the key to
peace